you  bogi approaching fast from the rear  [Music]  experimental maybe Sperry do not engage  the enemy  this is princess Rosa Cosette delese of  the kingdom of Arusha the ocm Federation  has forced construction of its giant  space elevator on our territory which is  clearly an illegal and unforgivable  violation of our nation's sovereignty  thank you are there any trolls verify  there is something I'll never get used  to what tonight has been a total shock  the princess encouraged her citizens she  kept the newest award turning the city  under martial law gunfire the roar of  jets echoing through the streets all the  remained was chaos  I wonder which path you would choose is  the parousia I don't even have a country  to call home  but it feels so far away now  engage I managed to catch a glimpse of  the three strikes  repeat Vietnamese many experienced  pilots in the ranks all era of caution  both  until I tested them myself  [Music]  you